if you really believe the issue with  guns is mental health  then why don't you actually support  funding mental health all of these  republicans tony gonzalez the republican  who represents uvalde texas greg abbott  the republican governor of texas over  the last two years they've all voted  against expansions to access to mental  health treatment and i will even go  further if you really believe the issue  is mental health why aren't you  supporting mandatory initial and  periodic psyche valves for anybody who  wants to own a gun i think we know why a  lot of those gun owners wouldn't be  allowed to own guns if they had to be  subjected to such an evaluation because  many of them aren't stable